that the emergency planes are being
given permission to land agent
permission by the Egyptians we will get
more information every 40 minutes
they're having ratings to say whether
the planes can come into the country
tell us a little bit about you know the
last day and a half view of waiting
because you were meant to go back to the
UK yesterday yeah we should have flown
five o'clock the older flights were
cancelled which we were aware of so
first thing in the morning we try to
find information help from our reception
we've got no information whatsoever they
told us to come back at about nine
o'clock or 10 o'clock when the reps come
here unfortunately that was ease day off
so we never had anybody to speak to they
don't speak very good English they
pretty good Russian which took a long
time the only thing we could do we the
information got from these eject was to
rebook your room it's incurred for up to
48 hours accommodation and at one point
they told you that it was because of
weather right we're in it to the
reception and said we're not flying
stone they said oh yes which is the bad
weather which which what she knows the
only information we was getting from the
nose there was no information was there
it was yeah easy then did send us
information as I said to rebook the
hotel well that took three hours yeah
they were sympathetic in any way
whatsoever all we wanted to do was
retain the
they were offering the rooms 250 pounds
a night first off which then went down
to 120 pounds and so on and so on so
they seem to be rife in this situation
to make money so eventually we dig that
a rumour about how past 1:00 yesterday
afternoon yeah travel Republic because
the hotel were marching down from 120
pounds what do you make of these new
restrictions that you can only take hand
luggage I know you can't well we've got
a lot of suitcases in that we've got a
little bags that we've just got a pack
up essential bits that we need for when
we get back in the UK yeah yeah do you
know when you'll get your luggage well
their side now for seven days they
shouldn't be months should be after
seven areas for your service rather an
erisa luckily most of its summer clothes
so there are we gonna be guaranteed that
you're gonna see your suitcases again
yeah are you at least relieved that
there are extra measures being taken
apart right
because we're not going we're getting
information that given you one time and
then that be canceled another time
they're more likely gonna stand your old
guy and then they're gonna take us to
our hotel yeah well they won't take us
to the hotel until forty minutes is up
again do another decisions made but then
it could be that we've got wait another
40 minutes before they make a decision
to take us to another hotel yeah there's
more lot to do great so we can't do
anything else apart from just hanging
around or we walk away and find another
hotel it might change the decisions and
we're not here
have you been concerned about the
security at airports in Sean Michelle
don't if you've been in other airports
in Egypt or five times yes two years ago
the security was a lot more than it is
now right yeah yeah yeah the security
has
yeah so you know they know I mean but
how do you know there is a terrorist and
there's no